the traditional caring decent man as it
seems toxic men are winning oh I'm sorry
I misunderstood that oh that's easy
because modern women don't want to be
wives and mothers
and so they just want to be little and
run around and and so you know that
doesn't that doesn't breed itself to
traditional men
yeah
bars I think the
the mother woman she doesn't care she
dates whatever she feels she can be the
traditional can be the free spirit it's
about the mood and where you are you're
embarrassing me
agree what are you saying the toxic
thing ain't it still bought a lot of a
lot of people are toxic now like it's
it's a norm like it's actually a normal
when you're not toxic they're confused
I'm not I'm being so serious that why
haven't you cheated on me yet that is
like what
because you know what it's real it's
just like what Pearl said earlier like
when I do the street interviews and I
literally have to say this every show
like this is a setup I'll be like have
you have do you have a toxic ex yes I I
don't even need to ask I just say wait
let's talk about your toxic ex that's
how I should start it now yeah and I'll
be like oh well he was toxic how long
was you with him oh three years five
years eight years 15 years on and off
like people like to label people all the
time the narcissist but we all have a
kind of issues it's really rare to find
like the perfect family where they don't
be with troubles with problems we all
have problems that's you yeah but the
thing is women pick though so like you
can say all of that but like if you are
a woman even if you're a toxic woman but
you want a stable home and want to be in
a stable situation you can find a guy
that will give you that but you choose
you know these bad guys and that's it
it's chemistry obviously yeah about
chemistry so what about chemistry bro
like you're an adult you need to make
better choices no I'm not saying you
personally but you're an adult it's like
when you talk to a lot of women it's
like they they they try they look at
themselves in like in a child like like
situation like oh well it's about
chemistry or it's not my fault what
about him and blah blah blah bro you're
an adult the reason I like it the reason
that they stay with those toxic people
is that they don't want to man up they
don't want to be the right type of woman
to
be a wife or be a partner maybe you can
choose the people you like and you stay
can you like exactly you can choose who
gets inside you
you heard exactly what I said you can
choose who goes inside you and plus is
not raw you don't you can choose you can
choose so even look at the end of the
day yeah you can want what you want and
feel attracted to it whatever you want
but in a day everyone usually settles in
one way or another so so it gets to a
point where you have to make educated
decisions educated choices bro if you
just run around with your head in the
clouds thinking you're leaving some
rom-com bro like you're gonna mess up
and if you look at Society now there's a
lot of single mothers there's a lot of
women that are just single in general
and a lot of women are depressed on meds
[Music]
yeah but that's not nothing different
that's always been like that throughout
history though there's always been a
percentage of guys that didn't get no
box no vagina nothing that's that's not
nothing new
go on thank you hey Mom
can you choose who you fall in love with
yes
explain
so
I feel like I'm being set up a little
bit
I don't know what I think I think that
there's this whole delusion of like
women today you know the modern woman
thinks she's the far better far more
perfect far more interesting than she
really is and so it's hard for her like
that's why everybody on the other side
feels toxic because they have flaws well
every human has flaws and if we don't
just hunker down and work through it
then it's always going to be that way
and it's like painful for me to listen
to some of this stuff because I can't
imagine all of the sleeping around I
can't admit I don't know what what would
promote that that feels horrible that
would be a horrible day for me
your entire life or you had more than
one or you're following your mom what do
you mean like my mom was with my dad
since she was 17 so and then I'm asking
are you following your mom path are you
just had one relationship no I wish oh
my gosh
no no
um I mean I'm not with that whole
y'all be in the streets the football
team you can you can have the football
team
um but
my goal is my goal is not to raise
modern women I mean yeah I mean I'm
looking to get married and have a family
so how many relationships you had that's
the 27 you said no I'm 26 26 so are you
in a serious relationship at the moment
um no I'm not and for an American
average that is what do you mean you
guys get married pretty much early in
America right
um 28 is the average for women
so you're ready would you fail your mom
if you don't get married until you're 28
you think
um well I'd like to get married sooner
rather than later I don't know what your
point is I know it's just a question
because like your mom had just a single
relationship and because you want the
parent style that you had so that's why
I'm asking yeah I mean I think I could
have made different choices
um where I ideally would have gotten
married younger but you know didn't
happen that way yeah we're here it's as
I'm saying yes but I think that's but
that's part of the whole issue with the
way that we are right now is that
everyone's like if it doesn't follow one
exact narrative then you aren't or you
are they are this and they're that and
we've got a label for everything and you
know my sister got married at 36. she
would have loved to have gotten married
at 20
um and had a house full of kids she had
one you know so I don't think but that
didn't make her less of a traditional
woman it made her you know she made some
bad choices she was in different
situations she chose a career for quite
some time not realizing that that career
caused her to sacrifice the other side
of it so I just think I think that women
in general have been sold a bill of
goods and how in what those compromises
are and so did you have a career or you
were yeah I was we ran a software
company for 33 years so that's great
tell them what you were a teacher would
you do what'd you do when Dad Dad said
I'm starting a software company uh I
mean we were I was 17 he was 22 when I
met him and at the time we were I was
working for him
writing code and not writing code excuse
me I was not writing code that is not
true I was writing documentation and I
was debugging software I went through
college as a to be a teacher but then in
the end we would have had to hire
somebody making twice what I was making
so I got on the bus and you know and I
had a wonderful career I loved my career
and just finished in December and you
know I had a great time but you know
that career never sacrificed the number
of times that I flew home to coach you
know I wanted I didn't want to miss
anything so the only way not to miss
things was to coach every sport they had
you know how hard that was hell it was
terrible I'd fly out go to meetings fly
home coach fly back out I do crazy ass
stuff but I did it because I knew my
kids while I had you know the decision
to have a career was I honestly it
wasn't what I thought through it wasn't
like I was like I wonder if I want a
career in hindsight I wished I would
have homeschooled my kids and not done
that but you know God put me in that
position and we had a business together
and it was it was very fruitful for our
marriage and for our family but it
wasn't without sacrifice and so my my
whole point my that rabbit hole sorry
about that that rabbit hole was just to
say that modern women and just people in
society they want to label you and stick
you in a box and that makes you
something you are you aren't you it you
know it is or it isn't and life isn't
that black and white a hundred percent
and so there's you know 40 year old
traditional women who aren't married and
there's you know I do you guys think a
women lost some kind of violent Society
because she's single and modern
with the marriage one and she lost value
if she's single and modern no because
like he put in peoples in let's say if
you're separate here because we talk
about the modern woman and you call like
his I think different like I don't think
a woman is because she's left with a
football team
I think he like it the man they normally
sleep with how many women we never know
and they never get names or labels for
them okay we've gone down that road
let's just like tackle that one real
quick like I just find that ridiculous
so basically okay there's a third
government that don't get no vagina zero
right that's the first point second
thing I'll just ask you do you think the
majority of women find the majority of
men attractive yes or no no no so most
men even the average ones even the ones
that do get boxed sometimes most of them
are pretty much getting rejected most of
the time by the majority of women right
yes men have to chase women right yes
men usually have to do a lot of
self-improve and get your money up bro
go to the gym bro just be confident bro
like make sure that you can make her
feel good in the bed bro all of these
kind of things a lot of kind of
pressures that men have on themselves
which which men put on them men put on
each other and women put on men as well
you gotta be making six figures and you
gotta be some of these things men can't
even control the the guy's height is
what it is there's a lot of issues a lot
of pressures that men go through just
just to get a girlfriend just to get a
wife yeah so if we compare it to a woman
most times if you wanted to go and get
laid right now and hook up with a guy
right now you could just go out of this
building go on the street you wouldn't
even have to go in anywhere just on the
street and say do you want to smash okay
he's gonna say yes that's as simple it
is you don't even you you could
literally go to the gym be sweaty and
stinky and still do that and there's
gonna be a guy that will do that
so when when you when people talk about
oh yeah but if a man smashes loads of
women oh it's like why is it a man's
allowed to do that or why does a man get
uh kind of like Praise And I'm not
saying yes he's good or bad I'm just
saying if in comparison to when a woman
does it she gets called like derogatory
terms the reason is is because he's easy
for a woman to do that it's easy you
don't take no skill no effort nothing
like you can do it right now any time of
the day you want thanks you know what
I'm saying yes like and and that's just
it um what women swipe right five
percent of the time on Tinder it doesn't
matter the age or the time when you're
women you just need to walk the bar and
you can't have any guy I agree with you
no and that's why women that's why when
women do it they're it's frowned upon
women because they can do it very easily
that's why it's frowned upon it's simple
I think I think the point like that
typically we talk about is typically the
more traditional women get swooped up
younger so if you're past a certain age
guys are going to start to think well
why aren't you in a relationship
so and that's that's true to me
especially if you're good looking like I
mean I would say the most traditional
women typically get swooped up before
like 25 typically
yeah I have a mixed opinions about it
because it depends or of course all the
environment at the age if they are well
educated oh it's going to depend of the
environment if they're gonna care if
you're still single or if you're it
depends on the environment I don't you
think it's really hard to generalize man
it's it's you want to say that but the
data just doesn't say that like if you
have never been married before 30 you're
actually you're not likely to get
married ever
so if you've never been married which
countries is research Italian America
database or this is uh this isn't this
is American uh in UK so I mean I'm not
we're in the UK I don't know what's
going on in Brazil no I live in Europe
and my family is in Thailand so I'm also
yeah but you live here in it no but I
lived in Italy before I lived in here
no I live here in UK but it's different
here I don't think I think it's
different here but you live here right
we're going to talk about what we are
living right here are you thinking about
leaving anytime soon I'm telling you
about Europe because now brexit okay
your case listen listen listen listen
like we're gonna talk about what's here
because we're here we live here and
you're dating here so what are you going
to talk about 30 years old here the
people it's not like she's saying yes
she's saying that the odds of getting
married over 30 are low in the UK just
like they are in the United States
cool
okay
all right I'd like to say if you've
never been married if you've already go
to the divorce list yeah yeah because
because it's like I guess I guess you
got a one-up they're like oh she's done
this before we can
as many of you know I was just being
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible